the food was very good
um prior to getting into the logical
fallacies that we'll be discussing in
the Q a session after that we'll be
talking about two more
um problems
often faced by Muslims in regards to
talking to non-muslims so somebody some
of the individuals in here requested
that I talk about slavery
um and I will talk about General slavery
first I want to talk about sex slavery
the so-called accusation of sex slavery
okay
um now I'm only going to offer two forms
of evidence in this regard
in order to refute this accusation I'm
going to I'm going to give you a comment
from Imam Malik okay
and I will give you a comment from Imam
Shafi okay that's it and uh you can
determine from their opinions it's one
of some of the two greatest masters of
our religion uh in terms of knowledge
um you can determine from these answers
whether or not sex slavery is and is
allowed in some form or another when we
mean by sex slavery is that somebody is
captured okay a woman is captured and
then you're allowed to have sex with her
against her will
okay so she is your slave so you can
have sex with her anytime you want even
if she doesn't want to
in fact this is not part of our religion
yes you can capture people you can't
enslave them we're going to talk about
that later but in terms of forcing
yourself upon a woman this is false if
we can see what email Malik says can you
raise up please
in our view the man who rapes a woman
regardless of whether she's a virgin or
not if she is a free woman
he must pay a dowry like that of her
peers and if she is a slave he must pay
whatever has been detracted from her
value the punishment is to be carried
out on the rapist and there is no
punishment of the woman who has been
raped
okay so even if she's a slave if she is
raped punishment shall be enacted on the
rapist
okay this means that it's not allowed to
rape
a woman even if she's a slave okay so
you cannot force yourself onto a slave
woman
all right
just a monitoring punishment that's it
monetary what kind of punishment well
let's see in a moment
okay if and here's Imam Chef who's
giving a little bit more context all
right he says if a man acquires by force
a slave girl then has sexual intercourse
with her after he inquires her by force
and if he is not excused by ignorance
then the slave girl will be taken from
him
he is required to pay the fine and he'll
receive the punishment of illegal sexual
intercourse
to be punished was enough
okay
volume two says uh basically then they
captured a pretty bad bride uh they
liked hers they captured then they had
sexual intercourse with her when he
completed his mission he felt guilty
with the Khalid and told him about what
he did Khalid said I permit you and made
it lawful to you this is Khalid he said
no not uh not no not until you write a
message to Omari and Omar answered that
he should be stoned
for having forced himself upon a woman
okay you should be stoned
for they captured a bride okay so they
made her a slave right he assumed that
this is my right hand possesses he then
had sexual intercourse with her okay
and then ordered for him to be stoned
for this action okay he ordered for him
to be stoned
uh some more evidences if you want uh
can we go a little bit further please
a little further a little further okay
okay there's just some uh more basic
statements but essentially rape in
general regardless if it's a slave woman
regardless if it's a free woman is wrong
you cannot force yourself upon us now
however however if you acquire a woman
all right and she understands that she
is
your right hand possesses as it is and
she agrees
without any problems then it's okay
course this is also including the fact
that you must provide for her and you
must take care of her and you've just
fulfill her rights etc etc not only that
the slave assuming which you have sex
with they have equivalent rights with
your wife and their children have equal
invest with your
legitimate children after you passed
away yes in terms of their inheritance
yes in terms of their Heritage there is
a little bit of a difference between the
official life and
the
the slave girl but in terms of how they
should be treated yes they should be
treated fairly they should be treated
with respect you know so but there is a
different status in regards to other
legal issues like for instance the slave
girl uh does something wrong then the
punishment will be halved on her whereas
if she's a free woman it'll be full so
that's a little different Ismail
yes if you treat them similarly yeah
uh the thing is is that
um this is a very
we consider this a very uncomfortable
subject as well
um this Islam permit slavery does it
just or does it disallow slavery this is
one thing the issue is this
um it allows slavery under certain
limited conditions and it promotes the
freedom of slaves okay it's like this
before marriage Arabia yes marriage
women were wives were equivalent to
animals people will post that I have 100
cameras 500 shapes and 20 wives it's
very cool what Islam did is change the
concept of Lies liberated the ideology
so now wives are equivalent to men yeah
better half so similarly Islam liberated
the ideology of slavery you can be
slaves but you could be much better than
an employee I was a general manager in a
shipping Corporation and I felt no
better than a Slave so it doesn't mean
you're a slave I mean abubakar for
example had an instance where someone
came and said hey I thought that guy was
your slave before so he still is he
dressed better than you he likes it and
they reached a stage where you can't
even insult your your sleep it has to be
willing to know something it must be
very much fair to the person yes and you
also understand that we cannot even slap
our slaves across the face they can be
they can be they can be they can get
their freedom as a result of that yeah
that if someone calls his slave ya abadi
oh my sleep he's freed to that extent
you know not even slapping even hurting
ego in public was not alone so yeah
there were certain there were many
limitations that were placed on the the
practice of slavery itself uh and in
fact it was discouraged on many levels
uh within the Quran and the Sunnah it
was inconsidered that uh a good deed to
free a slave as well especially for
expiation of certain sins so in terms of
how slavery is dealt with in the Quran
and the Sunnah it is not encouraged but
at the same time uh it is not disallowed
completely because it was trying to
gradually well there is an opinion that
it was gradually being abrogated however
it still is allowed within the Vic
um but like I said to a very very
limited degree so in terms of how we've
used slavery from the Western context
which is you just take them you treat
them like cattle and you beat them to
death and you treat them like they're
just objects this is not allowed in
Islam at all these people are still
people their legal rights are different
but they still must be treated as human
beings they can't be treated like a dog
you know you know or or a piece of
furniture or something of this sort
so in that respect when the concept of
ownership in Islam is also limited
compared to the Western context and this
actually shows a very sharp distinction
between how our cultures or our
religion's view the topic of ownership
or possession in the western conflicts
the reason they get so appalled by the
idea of people owning other people is
because their concept of ownership is
unlimited you know they have no respect
for what they own
they're all they're the things that they
possess have no rights
the land they possess everything they
can do whatever they want with it okay
whereas in Islam even the things that we
possess have rights
are animals
have rights
okay the land in which we we Farm has
rights the Earth has rights okay we
can't just do what we wanted
right so
um man it is uh this is not to say that
the West doesn't have concept of Rights
for like say animals for instance right
you know they they say that you can't
abuse dogs and cats in certain parts of
the world you know this is considered an
offense but compared to
um you know
um other things like they can still
abuse those things and they're okay with
it but
um because the animal rights movement
was very popular in the west especially
in the United States now they're
starting to include more punishments for
people who abuse animals etc etc so but
for Islam this has been around for a
long time I mean we've we've always
recognized that animals and other things
have rights so when we say that we
possess something it doesn't mean that
we possess it in total like Allah
possesses Us in total because we are
slaves to Allah so that means that we
don't have absolute freedom so whatever
we possess
okay whatever we possess we don't have
full control over
all right so
um the concept of possession and
ownership is a taboo in Western culture
when it comes to human beings however I
would argue that there's a lot of
slavery for instance in the west it just
goes under different names
the prison system is pretty slave-like
in the way that it's performed you know
many times when in Islam when we capture
people in Warfare we did so as a form of
prison to protect ourselves and to make
sure that you know that uh that they
were punished to some degree but in the
west they just throw them in a cage
and there's even work prisons they have
work prisons where they make them do
work for like 25 cents a day
so I mean that is slavery essentially
but they don't call it that
you know there are other forms of
slavery in the West
uh let's see the minimum wage
is quite low but people are still
working 40 50 60 hours and of course
they have the choice to work that's what
they're claim to but they don't really
um you know if they don't work then you
know they'll starve to death so there's
other forms of coercion okay
um so we also there's also something
called debt slavery I don't know if
you've heard of this concept debt
slavery basically people are in debt for
most of their lives they're enslaved to
the banks
okay and if they don't pay and people
take all their property away they have
rights over them in some respect
um I would even go so far to say this
and this is a philosophical statement
our children
or in some form or another
our slaves to some degree I wouldn't say
that they're completely slaves but what
I would say is that we own them we
possess our children okay to some degree
and say when I say my son
or my daughter I don't have any children
but if I say my what am I saying saying
that's I I this is mine I own this child
we don't say ownership because it sounds
very crude but in a way we are implying
that this isn't yours this is mine my
son we don't say that he's just an
independent person you know they have to
follow us they have no rights to do
whatever they want of course and if we
abuse them the state takes them away
so we have limitations in that regard as
well right so but you know so the uh the
understanding of possession
from the Western context is actually
much more crude and much more
what I'd say um barbaric
in our possession of possessions
um
uh so because in the western context
possession means something that has no
rights at all you can destroy it
whenever you feel like it you can burn
it you can throw it around Beat It To
Death you know it doesn't matter
so in terms of slavery
um
I think that would cover that uh
I'd like to talk about Hadoop and then
go straight into the fallacies because I
don't think we have much time left
so if we can switch this off can you go
into the fallacies page please thank you
had dude laws okay we were just talking
about this earlier
um I just want to mention some things a
lot of non-muslims especially
islamophobes like to object to the
punishments in Islam as being barbaric
or too severe okay so we're going to
mention Xena
uh the punishment for Xena okay if
you're an unmarried person it's lashes
correct lashes
and if you are married it's stoning okay
yes Stone to death
um when people hear about this they
cringe a little bit like oh you know
even Muslims we're kind of like
that sounds very bad right
but uh in fact in actuality it is a
deterrent all right it's very difficult
to prove
and it requires more witnesses now does
the act of Xena itself
does the act of Xena itself
is that what makes the punishment
possible can anybody answer me the
question does the act of Xena itself is
that what makes the punishment no
that's the mistake that people
that people often make when they
understand Xena it's not Xena itself
that's the reason it's being punished
it's because it's a Public Act
that it's being public that is being
punished
why because you need four Witnesses
right to see the ACT not video recording
nothing like this it needs to be four
Witnesses who have the exact same
testimony and if they're wrong if one of
them is wrong then the whole team is
considered wrong and then they get
lashed for making slander okay and then
their testimonies never accepted after
that all right so that's how difficult
it is for one in order for that many
people to catch you in the act you have
to be doing it like in KL Central in the
middle of everyone you know to even the
possibility for you to be caught
okay
so the reason it's punished is because
it's made into a public offense not
simply because somebody this is still
bad sleeps with somebody else unlawfully
but because you had the audacity to do
it in such a way that it becomes
publicly witnessed
okay that is the crime
it's a basically a public change it's a
Public Act of indecency to such an
extent that it must be punished in such
a harsh way to because remember there
are two things that make sure
that this act cannot be caught in
private
okay and I'm not encouraging anyone to
go do anything I'm just telling you that
that Sharia limits the possibility of
being caught in private by two reasons
one
you cannot spy
we are not allowed to spy at all so
these incidents where we find political
ministers being caught for Xena because
of the cameras being placed in their
hotel rooms this is Haram
this is absolutely Haram we cannot be
doing this trying to catch people doing
Xena because now we've made it a bigger
problem now we've showed it to the whole
world
okay
yeah you're not supposed to spy yes yes
it is
so uh and the other one
I just forgot so as you cannot spy
that's the first one and secondly you're
not allowed to enter anyone's property
without permission
so if you decide you're going to do
something bad and commit Xena it is
virtually impossible for anyone to catch
you if you're doing in the Privacy
you're in a home even if they video
record you you can't be punished for it
because you can't spy right
so in fact the act itself is not what is
punished it's the fact that you had the
nerve
to do it outside of the private context
and get caught by four people
I mean this is insane
this is somebody who has absolutely no
shame
okay and the Rarity of it being punished
is this is because the people who often
were stoned
for the act of Xena
at least in the past now is a different
story especially in places like Iraq is
because they went to the authorities
themselves and they confessed to having
done it and they wanted to be stoned
to uh to to release themselves of their
sins okay to repent so that was the
reason so that's how difficult it was
now I ask you is it really barbaric to
have such a harsh punishment
for somebody who would be brave enough
not brave enough stupid enough
to throw themselves in public and commit
such an indecent Act
this person is and I say this try not to
be so harsh this person is no better
than an animal if they're willing to
have sex
with somebody else
you know in a
in a public sort of area this is this is
somebody who's very you know what also
we will give you okay I want to ask you
you asked this question with American
students okay those who are a bit
open-minded in some of the open
metropolitan cities what would be the
response will be the response if you
caught them having no no if you ask this
question with American students okay
college students and all that they would
say that uh this act should not be
punished in such a way and that's
because the the open indecency of sexual
activity is accepted as the norm within
Society pornography for instance is very
accepted okay so they accept it as a
moral thing
as a more is something that's or amoral
or something that is okay to do now in
terms of adultery in terms of like
cheating on your wife or cheating on
your husband this is considered bad in
every culture however the way they treat
it is also depends
um a few things like for instance do you
remember what happened with Tiger Woods
he had like 17 mistresses
and he confessed to it you know
okay well for the first three months all
the women were saying he's a pig you
know he's a horrible person for doing
this okay and everyone was saying bad
things about him and the other the men
most of the men were saying oh
you know very good you know and and
within that culture okay not all of them
but many people and then after three
months nobody talked about it anymore
some counseling and something yeah but
nobody cares anymore if you talk about
Tiger Woods today
nobody mentions it
he's still playing golf he's fine he's
still married to his wife
she took half his assets but besides
that
he's still married to to her she's still
married I don't know why she's still
married because he has a lot of money
right but
um
but see that the cultural it's not
really a cultural taboo you know but of
course if somebody cheated on
if they were cheated on then we see a
different story
in fact there are many instances in the
west especially in the United States
where a man catches his wife in the act
and he kills
he goes to jail for it for murder but in
the court system in the United States we
have something called crime of passion
okay a crime of passion and it makes it
puts a limiter on the amount of
punishment and time he gets
okay he shouldn't have killed the person
they say but at the same time we
understand why you did it because you
were angry that your wife was sleeping
with somebody
you know else and they also excuse women
there was an incident in the United
States and I think even in China
recently where a woman cut her husband's
for cheating
and she didn't get any jail time
for for anything you know and that
and nobody ever and even if you look at
the news online you read the the
comments all the women are like yeah you
know they're like this awesome you know
and then they have the audacity
to claim that
you know that what we're doing is
barbaric as well for such indecent acts
that are done in public
okay and this is what they're doing in
private
right and they're getting punished for
it and yet for some reason there is no
outcry there's no uh whenever people ask
for somebody to be punished in India
recently I read a news report that a
child rapist was caught by the community
that he lived in they beat him to death
in the street
and if you read all the comments from
all the westerners they're like oh he
deserved it
he deserved it you know
so it's really fascinating it really
depends on it's sort of about what they
value and who they value when they make
these sort of judgments or whether or
not something is barbaric
okay and I'm going to give you some
other reasons why we should not take
people seriously when they mention these
things
but first I want to go into the another
Hadoop punishment which is when we cut
the hand off
okay it's for only a certain amount
okay the person has to be caught within
a certain amount of time all right
basically if they if they haven't made
repentance within about 48 hours
okay then
they haven't returned the object or
returned the monetary value of whatever
they have stolen and then we catch them
after a certain period of time then the
punishment can be applied so basically
there's a forgiveness period okay uh
also
um it can't be for any other reason like
it has to be for like a ridiculous
reason that they stole this it can't be
because they're starving or because of
anything else whereas in the United
States if you steal regardless if you're
starving or not you're going to jail
doesn't matter what your reasons are
um that's why you have a lot of African
Americans in prison a lot of poor
African-Americans in prison 70 of the
population because even though they're
poor and they're stealing and selling
drugs and things because they're trying
to survive they're still punished
regardless of this
um but what we do is that if the crime
if this if the theft is so heinous and
he's caught or the person is caught we
cut the hand off okay which serves as a
deterrent and we send them back into
society I mentioned this yesterday is it
better to have one severe punishment or
the individuals that reintroduced into
society no longer does the crime and he
serves as an example unto others okay is
that bad yes he's dismembered okay we
understand that but he can still survive
he can still eat he can still
communicate with people he can still
live a normal life most likely okay
whereas the person who goes to jail for
20 years
is stuck in a prison cell outside of
normal Community away from his family
not doing any work whatsoever not being
productive whatsoever okay being paid by
other people's tax dollars to stay into
and stay inside a cage
and basically being tortured
physically and socially and has been
around other criminals
can we describe any worse treatment in
my opinion
I think that a swift severe Act of
punishment is far better and far more
effective
than putting people behind cages for
years
for uh these sort of crimes
and I find it very interesting and this
is more of a philosophical point is why
especially Americans and Europeans why
are there so they they find what Muslims
do in terms of our legal system is so
unconscionable meaning so
um severe so barbaric quote unquote when
in fact
they endorse certain laws themselves
that would be considered barbaric by
their own standards such as how their
governments and I'm talking not
domestically I'm talking foreign wise
how their governments treat other
societies
for instance there are their perception
of collateral damage
or why the United States cannot be
punished
for having killed 80 percent of a
population that had nothing to do with
you know so basically killing the
majority of civilians usually this would
be considered a war crime
under any rational moral Society
standards but when the United States or
Europe uses Precision bombs to kill one
or two people ends up killing 20 or 30
instead
you know nobody questions that they say
well that's War it's not a big deal
I'll tell you the reason why
when people look on the news and they
see Muslims chopping heads off and
chopping hands and things they say this
is barbaric but when they they don't do
it when their president drone strikes
some children in Pakistan or Slaughters
thousands of people in the Iraq War
it's because of the visual
representation
it's not there
when they do something wrong they don't
show it they tell you about it they say
oh we drone strike somebody today but
they don't show the dismembered bodies
they don't show how the bomb dropped on
them and blew them to pieces
they don't show these things but when
they show Muslims doing something they
show the exact act from point A to point
Z
you know they show it in slow motion
sometimes they do it like when the
blood's coming out it's like it's almost
you know so they make all the details
you know they they increase the volume
when the somebody's screaming on the
audio you don't notice that anybody
notice that when you see a beheading the
audio goes up
when the ACT starts to happen
I don't know if you notice it's very
subtle they raise the volume really
quickly when the service starts
screaming so you hear it very clearly
okay even if there was a recently there
was a a woman who was executed in Saudi
Arabia she was Burmese because she raped
her her husband's daughter with a
broomstick
and killed her
I'm not joking that was the crime so
they executed her in public so they took
a video recording they showed they're
doing execution right they cut the
woman's head off
and as they're coming down with the
sword you hear very faint noises in the
distance right but as the sword comes
down he cuts its screams sounds like
it's like right in your ear
they increase the volume like right
there boom
and say oh see well the horrible act you
know see what's going on right
and then every all the people underneath
the comment section they're saying how
barbaric Muslims are
even though this woman just raped a
child
and killed her you know she was being
executed for that reason but they say
look how barbaric but then you know
somebody gets killed in India for raping
a child
everyone's okay
now you wonder
why is there such a difference
does it have to do with maybe media
portrayals does that to do with the
saturation I call this information
saturation or media saturation basically
what they do is they saturate your mind
with certain images that you're used to
okay and then you start to develop
negative portrayals of people
automatically regardless of what the
reasons may be
so if a Muslim kills somebody
people automatically think there's
something wrong with that person for
having killed if he killed somebody that
must be for a bad reason
but if somebody else kills somebody
okay why and then they start questioning
oh well why did this happen
well maybe it was for a good reason you
know maybe it was something like this
so oftentimes we see that people in the
west will commit similar crimes or
people that the West doesn't hate will
commit Center of crimes and westerners
will be okay with it if that person is
punished in what we consider an unfair
fashion or what they would consider
unfair fashion sometimes they're okay
with it but when Muslims do something
by their own legal standards
and I'm just there was considered
barbaric as a result of that
but probably the best argument to use
against people who are against Hadoop is
this
even if they believe it's barbaric or
not
even if they believe it's barbaric say
you can't convince them and it's not
barbaric
we have something called social contract
and this is a philosophical position
that I want you to understand it's
called social contract and this was
developed during the time of John Locke
okay he was a famous uh philosopher who
encouraged
democratic values and things like this
he was used as a template for the
American Revolution and American
Constitution okay his name is John Locke
now what he believed is that when people
get together and they decide upon their
laws they have a right to practice those
laws amongst themselves okay
social contract if they if they if they
want a punishment for themselves if
everyone agrees to this then they should
be allowed to punish themselves how they
wish
okay because they've all decided on it
so well if so if Muslims for instance if
in Egypt are 98 of them or something say
they want Sharia
they should be allowed
to implement it among themselves that's
what it should be
westerners don't think that way they
think that social contract only applies
to themselves
okay they believe that it only applies
within their type of societies and their
values but if Muslims want to get
together and form a government like a
caliphate or they want to form a
government that implements a Sharia to
its fullest extent
we can't allow that so we have to bomb
them
okay
so I will find it more barbaric actually
that
Western standards are being imposed upon
Muslims
who don't want those standards
and want to be punished among themselves
as they wish
has anybody ever asked some of these
women who are stoned whether they agree
with the stoning
no has anybody ever asked some of the
people get their hands cut off if before
they got caught they agreed with this
punishment
anybody
of course nobody loves to be punished
nobody wants to be punished regardless
of what the punishment is but that's not
an argument did that person agree with
these principles before they got
punished for instance if I am a Muslim I
am a Muslim and I'm walking into and I
and I understand what the punishment for
theft is and I agree because it's in the
Quran and the Sunnah but I want to steal
anyway and I think I can get away with
it
all right I've already agreed that this
is the right punishment
all right and so what if it happens to
me
then
am I I mean is it unjust when I've
already said it's okay
is it unjust to punish me in a way that
I've already agreed to
see it's not right but no Westerner asks
this question
when they ask about the people being
punished to the people themselves agree
with the punishment
and the reason I bring this up is
because of this when I bring up this
argument somebody asked me would you
want to be stoned
do you want to be so of course I
wouldn't be I don't want to be stoned he
said so see
you disagree I said no I just don't want
to be stoned it has nothing to do with
me agreeing or not it's a loaded
question
said we don't want to implement because
all the Malaysia will be working with
one hand later on so it's as if like
saying does it mean all of us are
thieves besides that but I mean it's a
that's a that's more of a exaggerated
generalization and it's it's a very
it's it's a it's a faulty thing to say
because if everyone is stealing then
there's something wrong with the society
you shouldn't be implementing it anyway
but that's besides the point but um
what I want to say is that just because
you don't like the punishment
like you don't want to be punished
doesn't mean that the punishment is
wrong because there are people all over
the world who don't want to be punished
by their own laws nobody wants to go to
prison
but that doesn't mean that prison is
okay a prison is not okay for instance I
would use the same argument against the
westerners that who often bring this up
the non-muslims they say if you don't
want to be stoned that means you
disagree you don't want to implement it
I said you want to go to jail
said no then you're against prison
so that means what then so so you
disagree with your own laws
they said no I agree with my own laws so
then so do I so what's your what's your
point
and we call this an appeal to emotion
this is also a fallacy appeal to emotion
where you try to use people's emotions
to prove a point
oh this makes you feel bad that must
mean it's wrong
no that doesn't mean it's wrong
okay
so the so the understanding of barbarism
even if they think it's barbaric
my main problem is whether or not they
want Muslims to not be able to do it or
not
see I could care less of the kufar I
think we're barbaric to be honest I
really could care less my main concern
is whether they want to draw bombs on us
because we want to practice it that's my
biggest concern
and to me that's more barbaric
you know
then then what we're trying to implement
because at least we've agreed upon it
that we want this for ourselves if I
tell you I want to be lashed for
committing some form of offense okay
I've already agreed to that punishment
then it's not unjust if it's being put
on me because I've agreed to it if the
Western non-muslims consider and say
it's okay to kill yourself it's not
against the law you can do with what
your own body as you want then why is it
that we cannot choose how we wish to be
punished so it's okay for them
it's okay it's not against the law to
kill yourself in certain many countries
in the world many Western countries it's
okay it's okay to mutilate yourself
it's okay to do whatever you want with
your body they even say it's okay to
have abortion because it's her body you
can do whatever you want with it
right because you own your body but if I
want to be punished a certain way I
can't do that
that's a country that's hypocrisy
it's a contradiction in their ideals
so as long as I kill myself they're okay
with it but if I want to lash myself
it's it's a problem
you know
it seems to me that they are you know
have these particular values and they
think that their values is uh you know
better and they want to impose it on us
superiority thinking crafting
superiority thinking came in with a lot
of the ideas that I mentioned earlier
actually with their scientific
advancement technology uh what they
consider to be freedom but there's a lot
of things that they have in mind which
are which which they contradict
themselves on many levels and it's
really a superiority complex entrenched
in a form of
well I could say racism there is a high
level of racism Within These sort of
societies whether they want to see it or
not so for instance we look at free
speech what happened in France recently
what happened in France
Charlie hebdo correct
so some Muslims went in and killed
12 people and including some more later
in the Jewish market and because of the
depictions of the Prophet saws right or
they were right huh they left all the
evidence there there's other things we
could talk about but that's besides the
point my main point in this is that
thank you
after that the French they all got upset
and they said look freedom of speech
okay we stand for absolute freedom of
speech absolutely
okay we can say whatever we want
whenever we want
but not the Holocaust yes but then
something else happened after that three
days later
and this is really funny there was a uh
comedian
and I can't pronounce his name for love
you know doing or something I don't know
anyways he uh he said a comment on his
Facebook he said I feel like was it
Charlie uh he mentioned the name of one
of the killers
and what he was trying to get at he was
saying is that I feel like I have Free
Speech but at the same time I'm treated
like a bad person that was his intention
behind the statement he explained it
later but they claim that he was
endorsing terrorism
they arrested him the next day
okay
um also France has strict laws against
anti-Semitism the same magazine
the same newspaper that published The
Prophet Muhammad's cartoon right uh they
fired one of their editors for drawing
an anti-semitic or making anti-semitic
comments okay within the mag within the
same right you also cannot deny the
Holocaust I wouldn't deny the Holocaust
but you know it's still we're talking
about Free Speech right
okay
there are also many laws in the west
including the United States against
slander and libel you're not allowed to
say lies about people that would hurt
their reputation
okay you can be punished for that right
so there's no absolute freedom of speech
there
um
so
in many ways they like to look at the
Muslim world and when our sensibilities
our things get offensive or what are we
feel offended or when the sacredness of
our beliefs is destroyed okay or our
Prophet salallahu Islam is slandered
we can't get angry so
um it's really difficult to take many
people seriously when they claim that
certain things are barbaric in our faith
but at the same time they endorse things
that are far worse
um so I'm not saying that they're wrong
for being Hypocrites but I'm saying that
they have no right to speak
when they themselves consider acts that
are 10 times worse than what we do in
our countries
they consider those to be moral and
Justified
so I would usually turn it around on the
person when they start to question us
about how we punish people
has anybody asked how the United States
punishes people
what happened to Iraq before the war
anybody know
the sanctions
do you know what those sanctions did to
those 500
000 children died
children alone
because of sanctions because of a
political disagreement
the Iraq was never a threat to anyone I
mean they didn't they didn't deserve
so 500 000 children had to be killed
for what
and then they blame Saddam Hussein they
say oh because he ain't given to our
demands
so it's okay so he said it's his fault
that 500 000 children died
really
did he ask you to put sanctions on him
does Iran ask for those sanctions
as well I mean whatever you want to
disagree with Iran or not okay do they
deserve what they're getting I mean did
they really deserve that
when Russia invades Ukraine it's bad
but when the United States invades and
bombs 14 Muslim countries in the past 20
years that's really it's okay so you
know that's fine so there are a lot of
double standards based on power politics
okay
uh that's why everyone in the U.N
disagrees with Israel does to the people
in Gaza but the United States always
vetoes it
every single time
every single time even when it's just
Israel in the United States agreeing
with this one thing and everyone else is
against them they veto
so there is a superiority complex
um
so um I would say that
I have I have had many arguments with
people like this and the first thing
that I like to do is I like to point out
the things that they endorse and I don't
do it because I want to prove that my
argument is right because we're going to
get into one of the fallacies it's
called Uh
to kokri okay it means pointing the
finger it means that you're wrong
because you're a hypocrite
but see that's that's actually a fallacy
you can't say that that person's wrong
because they're Hypocrites they're a
hypocrite they're a hypocrite but
they're not wrong because they're
hypocrite okay somebody could say one
plus one is two
you know and they're still right even
though they're hypocrite about something
you know it doesn't matter
so they could say that something is
wrong morally and still be a hypocrite
you know if I say murder is wrong but I
murder somebody it doesn't mean that I'm
that all of a sudden I'm wrong about
murder
it just means that I'm a hypocrite
that's it so we have to understand that
that's also a policy
so if we can go on we'll go to the
fallacies now I've been rantsing I'm
sorry so um I'm gonna just go through a
few of them okay
so we're going to mention the first one
is called the ad hominem I'm not going
to go through this whole list it's like
200. okay so this is at the ad hominem
what is an ad hominem
actually no
sorry a personal insult people often
think it's a personal insult an ad
hominem is this it means that you're
wrong
because of what I'm saying insultingly
about you like okay so this is how an ad
hominem would be
okay you're wrong because you're an
idiot that's an ad hominem that's it
it's just an insult used as a way to say
that somebody is wrong okay you're
you're you're you smell bad
so you have to be wrong you're too fat
you have to be wrong something like this
something that's personal about the
person and they use that as an excuse or
not an excuse as a way of saying that
that person's wrong about their argument
and actually you hear this quite a lot
especially online you see people saying
just insulting things they say oh this
person is an idiot so they must be wrong
that's it so that's been called an ad
hominem that's one of the most common
fallacies okay if we can keep going
please
stop
add ignorantium add ignorantium we also
call this a fallacy from ignorance
this is how it works I don't know
therefore it's wrong
or I don't know therefore it's right I
know that sounds ridiculous but let me
give you this
we don't know God exists therefore he
must not exist
and actually you might see some atheists
sometimes saying this actually
okay
uh keep going
stop appeal to Authority can we click on
that one
they appeal to Authority this is the one
is actually very much
misunderstood but it's a very good one
to know okay and many people make the
the accusation make this felicious
acquisition all the time they say people
are appealing to Authority and it's
wrong but they use it wrongly and I'll
explain how it works
okay so when you do the appeal to
Authority fallacy it's when you you
claim that because an authority said it
it must be correct or it must be wrong
so for instance if I if I cite if I make
a citation of a doctor in regards to a
medical issue okay I'm citing him as an
authority right
right is this okay though
because he's a he's a doctor
so say he's a medical doctor so it would
be okay for me to cite him as a
reference if I don't know the subject
so for instance I would I would cite a
faki for a fake opinion right is that
okay because he's a he's an expert
now what if I were to say that okay
there's something wrong with your engine
in your car because the medical doctor
says this
that's the appeal to Authority that's
when it becomes a fallacy is when the
authority in question is not an
authority
but you use him as a source anyway
that's when it becomes a problem and
you'll see this all the time for
instance atheists will always reference
scientists
talking about God
okay when they have no qualifications in
philosophy or theology or anything
okay this happens all the time
in fact even happens among us some
people will say uh politicians for
instance when they have no clue what
they're talking about so which is
probably usually like 90 of the time but
um so if I said something ridiculous
like uh
foreign
you know I don't know the theory of
gravity is true because the president
said so
okay that would be like an appeal to
Authority that'd be ridiculous right so
that's that's when it becomes a problem
but it's never a problem to cite
references who are actually authorities
on the subject it's not a problem okay
so can we go back sorry
okay
uh good there's a lot of these that you
can appeal to emotions we already
discussed that one okay it makes you
feel bad so it must be wrong or it makes
you feel happy so it must be correct
okay
there's about there's more than this
this is about 200 I think there's
roughly near four or five hundred
fallacies
these are official terminologies in
regards to what a fallacy is and yes
human beings can be this unreasonable
that's why we have so many so there's a
lot of people who've made a lot of
really bad arguments
um keep going appeal to past practice or
pilter tradition that's what the quraish
were using when they were trying to back
their opinions about their religion they
said we're following our fathers
okay so that's actually a fallacy of
reasoning
okay
appeal to the Mob can we click on that
this is also called appeal to popularity
you hear this a lot a lot
and and it's called statistics
yeah or appeal to popularity
[Music]
okay my idea is right because everyone
else agrees with me
because the majority of people agree
with what I say so it must be correct
this is called democracy
um I'm kidding right but that was a
slight joke but okay um
so this is actually a fallacy of
reasoning so just because the majority
of people believe something doesn't mean
it's true now you could say to me in
response well what about my ideas about
the fitra oh
am I making an appeal to popularity
because most people
have the federal have this conception of
God in their mind am I saying it's
rational because of that no
I'm not necessarily saying that I'm not
I'm sorry I'm not saying that it's true
I never claimed in this whole entire
talk that the belief in God is true
because of the number of people I have
claimed that it's more rational as a
result of being
you know something that normatively
everyone shares it's more rational it's
a rational starting point so it's
rational to have that belief okay and I
even have an argument of course I backed
it up by proving the other side wrong
right but I never claim that the belief
in God is true
because of that so it's not a fallacy
actually
but I've been I've been I've been
accused of making it before so uh can we
get
go back
uh go up
repeal our qualified authorities the
same thing uh argument from ignorance is
at ignorantium we just discuss that okay
uh
bandwagon is also considered the
argument from popularity can we go to
begging the question
begging the question is when you include
in your conclusion
a premise the premise and the conclusion
at the same time
when you're trying to argue for
something you include the conclusion
within your argument already before you
come to the conclusion so let's read the
sentence women have rights
said the bullfighters association
president but women shouldn't fight
Bulls because a bullfighter is and
should be a man
okay
why shouldn't women why shouldn't women
fight Bulls
what's the argument
because of both
it's a
because a bullfighter is a man
right
but he putting the conclusion in the
argument yeah yeah so he's already he's
there's no justification he's just
saying it he's so it's just an assertion
right this is what we call begging the
question so that's why why is it called
begging the question because it begs the
question as to why you think this
is
another example
uh let me give you um here we go
oh okay hold on
the argument is contained in the
premises conclusions contained in the
argument
um because women shouldn't fight Bulls
it's okay for instance the Bible I don't
know if you've heard this argument
before the Bible is the word of God why
because God
inspired the Bible
that's begging the question do you see
the problem
or even say in the Quran the Quran is
the word of Allah why because Allah
said
we've said that the Quran was the word
of Allah that's begging the question
it's when you put the conclusion in the
argument itself and many people actually
make this argument
unknowingly sometimes so uh
can we go back please
okay
stop
can we go to Sir cherry picking the
evidence please this is also called the
fallacy of suppressed evidence I've
discussed this on several times
uh where is cherry picking
oh why'd it go there can we go
oh okay can we click on that one
thank you
okay
all right so suppressed intentionally
failing to use information suspected of
being relevant and significant is
committing the fallacy to express
evidence this fallacy usually occurs
when the information counts against
one's own conclusions so say you're
reading an article okay you're trying to
prove one of those atheists wrong right
and he goes researching and you find an
article that's against you and you just
conveniently ignore it
okay when you're presenting your
argument next time this will be called
the fallacy of suppressed evidence we
should not do that even when the
conclusion seems to count against us we
should try to be as Fair as possible in
revealing what actually is the case okay
we should object to the arguments and
and the evidence that we have at hand
all right or we should use it when it's
available but many people don't so for
instance remember those Quran passages
that were listed and the one that was
conveniently left out
okay that's selective attention or
cherry picking or what we call
suppressed evidence and this occurs a
lot of times in order to find out
if it's happening all you need to do is
do some research if you find that
there's evidence contrary to the
person's conclusions you can list it and
say look
your argument is invalid because you
forgot to account for this information
and that's all you need to do so we go
back please twice back twice
okay go up
okay
confirmation stop confirmation bias
confirmation bias is very similar to
suppressed evidence but it's a different
uh way of of uh bringing about an
argument
so confirmation bias is when you're
selective of the evidence as well but
it's more of an intentional act in which
you you only select evidence that
confirms your agenda already so it's
also similar to what we saw in the Quran
I don't know their intentions but I'm
pretty sure they left it out on purpose
because you know it's it seems a little
bit too convenient that the Ayah right
before the one that you're reading you
can't include
yeah so this one is more deliberate like
so
okay yes yeah
exactly they they deliberately leave out
that context so this is confirmation
bias
um in this statement we we can see of an
example of it she loves me and there are
so many ways that she has shown it when
we signed the divorce papers in her
lawyer's office
okay she wore my favorite color
all right when she slapped me at the bar
and called me a handsome Pig
she used the word handsome
okay when she didn't have to
when I called her and she she said never
to call her again she first asked me how
I was doing whether my life had changed
when I suggested that we should have
children in order to keep our marriage
together she laughed
so you see how he's interpreting
all these negative situations he's
trying to find the good things in there
to confirm what he already wants to
believe
see
okay so can we go back
okay up
uh distraction can we go to distraction
please
uh
okay now go back sorry
do you remember I saw this yeah
uh genetic genetic can we go genetic
policy please
okay I've discussed this earlier
um
okay genetic fallacy is like this we
blame we say that something is untrue
because of where it came from
this is a problem
so for instance if Hitler anyone
everyone here knows who Hitler was right
okay he killed a lot of people so if
Hitler said one plus one equals two
and I say no he's wrong because he's
Hitler
right or if he told me that you
shouldn't murder people
but then I go he's wrong because he's
Hitler
that would be a genetic fallacy okay so
you claim that because the thing in
question is a bad
reference without any justification
other than the fact that you don't like
that person or something that means that
it's called a genetic fallacy okay
it's a kind of ad hominem it's very
similar to insult it's like saying
you're wrong because you're stupid okay
can we go back
uh guilt by association this is a lovely
fallacy I need you to remember
guilt by association
did we click on that
okay a guilt by association is when you
include is when okay for instance
uh this is this happens by islamophobes
all the time guilt by association what
they do to Muslims okay a Muslim
blew himself up in a crowded area and
killed some people
you're a Muslim too
so you must be responsible
oh
Collective punishment basically you have
the same label or you look the same so
you must share the same guilt guilt by
association
okay see this is a fallacy of reasoning
this is an actual fallacy of reasoning
see how philosophy helps so much and how
they don't practice it in the media so
yes ma'am
this is a very similar to an ad hominem
but it's more for a group
but instead of instead of saying you're
wrong what it's saying is that you are
responsible or you share the same
beliefs or you share the same
consequences as this person or these
group of people because you share the
same characteristics
okay so I'll give you another example
say a woman did something wrong that
means all women should be punished for
it or all women believe the same thing
that that person believes
okay they're all so you see just because
you're a woman
so in the same way they say about Muslim
they say because this Muslim did this
that means that because you share a
label or you share a certain type of
belief that means that you are also
responsible for that activity without of
course pointing out exactly what you're
response or why you're responsible it's
just because of your label or because
you have a similar characteristic
okay so this is called a guilt by
association fallacy this is unfair
yes it is a form of ad hominem that is a
form of ad hominem
okay can we go back
stop is odd can we go to the is odd
fallacy please thank you
okay example
because somebody is doing something or
because something is the case it's like
something is happening that means that
one should or should not do it
so it doesn't give justification
okay so it is ought so it is happening
so it ought to be the case
this happens a lot so for an example he
is torturing the cat
so he shouldn't do that
okay there's no argument
here it just assumes
on the basis of the accusation just on
the Assumption alone that it's wrong
that's it okay this is actually occurs a
lot you need to look for it it occurs
quite a bit in certain places and I'll
give you another example
um of something related to this
uh can we go up please
subscribe
oh can we go to naturalistic fallacy
thank you the naturalistic fallacy is
like this okay
okay
since women are naturally capable of
burying and nursing children they ought
to be the primary care givers of
children okay since women have babies
they should be the ones to take care of
the babies actually this is a fallacy
because it doesn't explain
anything
he just explains that what is happening
because she has a baby she must take
care of the baby
okay
and it says because they're naturally
capable of doing so all right but this
is actually fallacious now you can make
the argument that women are better based
on other evidence
okay that may be okay like sharing that
showing statistics that show that women
are more capable in this form and that
it actually is better if they do it
rather than men based on other evidence
but you can't say just because they're
naturally inclined to it that they are
better
at doing it so for instance people tend
to be naturally inclined to want wealth
but that's not actually not necessarily
a good thing you know it doesn't mean
that we should go and become greedy as a
result of that so we're naturally
inclined to have well so if she would
become greedy and try to be as rich as
possible and not care about anybody else
that's another way of of saying the
naturalistic fallacy some people say
that it's natural to rape
some people have actually made this
argument that it's actually natural to
rape
okay did you say that
I think that's pretty disgusting
okay yeah
is it natural to rape so he gave
something
so there's also something opposite of
this and I'm going to give you the other
fallacy that's often used by
islamophobes and they called it the
moralistic fallacy okay or sorry the
moralist fallacy it's called the
moralist fallacy it's the opposite of
this all right it's a moralist fallacy
it's saying what's happening and it's
very similar to is ought fallacy okay
what's happening in the legal system is
what's actually happening in the country
okay
but that's not true for instance in the
United States everyone has equal rights
in the United States according to law
but are they treated equally
no
they say this about Muslim countries
Sharia is implemented
in Saudi Arabia
so it must be like this
across the board in Saudi Arabia must be
exactly how it happens by the book
right or there or they say uh Malaysia
it's a Islamic country so they must have
Sharia
implemented across the board because
they say they're an Islamic country
right that's another version
okay another way of saying that is a
hasty generalization too it's it's not
appropriate but it doesn't take into
account what's happening on the ground
what's happening actually in the place
that people are living is only looking
at the legal codes and assuming from
there that something must be happening
in those countries without understanding
that sometimes people don't practice the
law some people don't implement it
sometimes there's contradictions some
people look for loopholes things like
this okay that's actually a fallacy so
we have to be very careful unless we
live somewhere we've studied something
we shouldn't assume by their legal books
or by what they say on TV that this is
actually what's happening we have to be
very careful about that and they do this
to Muslim countries all the time
basically yes that's a good way of
putting it they judge the book by its
cover
so can we go back please
okay no true Scotsman yes now we're
getting to my favorite ones
okay
all right and no true Scotsman is
basically this this is you'll hear this
a lot from atheists this is probably one
of the only fallacies that atheists know
about
okay now when you say to an atheist well
say Okay a Muslim a terrorist does
something bad right and they say look at
what Islam is like
and then you say to that person that
person wasn't a true Muslim
that person was not a true Muslim they
were not following Islam appropriately
the atheists will respond that's a no
true Scotsman fallacy
what does that mean
it means that so here's an example
all scotsmen are loyal and brave so
Jones says but McDougall over there is a
Scotsman and he was arrested by his
commanding officer for running from the
enemy and then well if that's right it
just shows that medieval wasn't a true
Scotsman it wasn't a true Scotsman
meaning that he wasn't or it wasn't a
true Muslim right they weren't a true
Muslim
okay so when we say that it's actually a
fallacy
it's actually a fallacy okay because the
person claims to be Muslim okay now we
can argue and say whether that person
was following Islam appropriately that
we can say that's not Islamic
okay we can say that but in terms of how
they Define themselves okay
um it's considered a fallacy to suggest
because what defines a Muslim is simply
he follows the Quran or he follows he
believes in Allah he falls the five
pillars of Islam moves in Prophet
Muhammad these basic attributes so
because of the definition that's how
they argue but you can still claim that
that person wasn't following Islam
appropriately they were not doing what
Islam commands and if somebody says that
you're doing a no true Scotsman fallacy
because you say
that this is not Islam then actually
they're wrong
that's not a fallacy
and I'll tell you why
because if Islam was just what everyone
does what everyone thinks Islam is then
Islam wouldn't be anything it would be
everything
so you have to say Islam is is not this
somewhere because if you don't then you
can't Define Islam right there's some
people who don't pray there's some
people who think Islam allows a
ridiculous things some people who
believe Islam says you don't have to
worry hijab there are a lot of people
who think Islam is a lot of things so if
we included all of those in Islam then
Islam would be a big contradiction
so Islam has to be something it has to
be one thing right
so it's okay to argue in that sense can
we go back
non-sequitur this is another good one
okay
okay non-sequitur means in logic means
does not follow does not follow
what does that mean it means that the
premises the premises do not follow to
the conclusion
means they do not equal the conclusion
like one plus one equals three that
doesn't make any sense
that's a that's an error in math but
that would also be considered a
non-sequitur okay
so here's an example nuclear disarmament
is a risk but everything in life
involves a risk every time you drive in
a car you are taking a risk if you're
willing to drive in a car you should be
willing to have disarmament
doesn't follow though
it doesn't follow what is it what's the
connection between the car and the and
getting rid of nuclear weapons for God's
sake it doesn't they say it's the risk
but they're not similar in any way
whatsoever right and there are many
reasons why
but you'll make you'll see people making
arguments like this okay all the time
all right you have to be very careful
and while we're at it I'm going to
mention another fallacy is called the
fallacy of equivocation equivocation
okay it's a fallacy of equivocation and
what that fallacy is is when somebody
uses a word
in a different way in the same sentence
or the same argument
okay
so okay I'm going to give you maybe two
more and then we're going to finish up
here can we go
no choose not secular when I'm
positioning out right keep going
stop please
I don't want to do Post talk okay point
this out back
here we go poisoning the well please
poisoning the well is a form of ad
hominem fallacy as well
and it's also very similar to the
genetic fallacy okay it's when you talk
about somebody
all right it's a preemptive attack on a
person so it's like an ad hominem before
before you give your argument actually
you say look you go to everyone you say
you shouldn't listen to this person
this person's a liar
okay don't listen to their arguments
they're lying to you right you see what
I'm doing so you're preemptively trying
to sell your argument by first claiming
that this person is wrong because of
some flaw that they have
okay why would you trust that person
remember what they did in this time
foreign
doesn't mean just because this person
has a flaw
doesn't mean that what they're saying is
wrong
they could be making a good argument
they could be correct in their just
because they have bad character doesn't
mean that
that the argument they're giving is is
incorrect we should accept the argument
based on its own standards not because
of the person's
you know immorality or the fact that
they made a mistake or something else or
because they're not intelligent
okay this is wrong
um
can we go back
up
uh
stop
okay now up again
smokescreen can we do this full screen
please sorry
I I actually want to get through more of
these but I don't think we're gonna have
time
okay
all right it's it's a form of the
suppressed evidence policy but it's even
um
it's basically what you do you'll notice
this about atheists especially okay this
is very pertinent to them what they do
is that they try to give you a lot of
information at once okay like I
mentioned like all the Quran ayas they
give you like 90 okay what they're doing
is they're trying to overload you
they're trying to give you so much
that's why I call a smoke screen you
can't see beyond you know it's so much
there that you can't concentrate and
what they do is they try to refute you
this way so you give you offer too many
details in order to either to be obscure
or to cover up counter evidence so
because a person is focusing on all this
information they can't think of the
right objections
okay of what to do how to they can't
focus
and this is common a lot of people like
to do they like to throw everything at
you at once so they know you can't
answer them okay try to avoid doing this
and when you see it point it out for
what it is so uh if somebody wants to
argue with you ask them first look can
we focus on one thing at a time please
and if they say no I want you to answer
everything and say okay I'm sorry this
is this is not we're not going to do
this okay
really yeah
arguments on Bible to Dr William
Campbell and he had a headache of
answering you know yeah that's all but
both see both cases is actually
inappropriate to do that because in fact
the reason for it is simply to overwhelm
your opponent is just to overwhelm them
it's not to give the right answers or to
give the right objections is to make
sure that that person can't respond to
you
yeah but even in debate
yeah
yeah I understand but what I'm trying to
say is that even in a formal debate
session you shouldn't be doing that you
shouldn't throw 40 questions out or
throw 40 objections because you know
that within the time that you have it's
impossible to answer that and that's why
they're doing it
yeah that's wrong okay so I would have
told him look you know you answer them
yourself so
um and I want to get to the red herring
can we go back to that section
got a smokescreen please
can you type on red herring
okay this is another uh very important
fallacy to remember a red herring is a
smelly fish that was distracted even a
bloodhound okay it's a discretion that
leads the Reasoner off the track or of
considering all the relevant information
it's a form of the smoke screen fallacy
but you don't have to overwhelm your
opponent what you do sometimes is you'll
throw in some information in there to
distract the person
okay so say if we're talking about
something in Islam right say somebody
objected to me about say Aisha the issue
that we talked about before and as I'm
discussing that with them all of a
sudden they throw in Hadoop
they're like okay I know I want to talk
about this and you're not even finished
your point so instead of letting
allowing you to give the evidences and
to be able to counter them they've
switched the subject to get away from it
it's called a red herring so when
somebody does that to you you said I'm
sorry let me finish we'll get to that
point later okay but actually a lot of
people in debate especially religious
debates when they see the atheist
subjects they switch with them
and then it gets into this lengthy
you know people write novels in online
in Facebook I don't know if you notice
this you know when they argue with each
other and if you look at these religious
arguments it's all over the place
at one point somebody's questioning
something then he answers then he goes
into something else he answers he keeps
going going going going and there's
nothing has ever resolved
so try to get away from that can we go
back
and one more time okay
uh UPS
okay straw man we already know this okay
good uh subjectivists
it's a logistic thing to cookware we
know this
this is the one pointing the finger
you're a hypocrite
so you're wrong that's actually a
fallacy okay can't do that
like just because if somebody comes up
to you and they don't pray and they say
you should pray you can't say you're
wrong because you're a hypocrite because
yes you should pray
it doesn't mean that that person we do
this a lot to our family members we say
they come up to us and they tell us to
do something we're saying well you don't
do it
right to get away from it right but
actually that's wrong because it doesn't
that's actually fallacious you can't say
that that doesn't mean that they're
wrong
so we we do that a lot actually that's
one of the most common things that we do
to each other if we don't like to be
corrected we tell somebody of their own
flaws
if we try to get away from it but in
fact you're still wrong it doesn't
matter so
when somebody does this to me I say okay
you're right I'm a hypocrite or
something but now does that mean that
you're wrong
because you're telling me well but you
do this okay so that means I'm right
then you do do this then right so
um
wishful thinking keep going
okay I think we're going to be good
there
so the U2 fallacy is also the is this
another word for another way of saying
uh
too quick okay
excuse me
false what false flag false flag attack
a false flag is not a fallacy but it's a
it's a strategy yeah it's a strategy of
War
um there are other
s okay I want you to actually write this
website down
it's www.iep
dot UTM not UTM here okay it's somewhere
else University of Michigan
utm.edu okay this website itself is
probably the best online reference for
all philosophical topics if you find a
philosophical word online you can type
it in the search engine all the articles
on this website are peer reviewed by
other philosophers
that means they're all all the articles
are written by philosophers and are
critiqued by philosophers in the
academic realm not just random people
like Wikipedia okay and if you go to the
fallacy section
okay you can look up all the individual
fallacies if you want to study more just
in case you decide to look into this
more in depth the ones that I've given
you are probably are actually very basic
I learned these in philosophy 101
the other ones that you saw on there I
will not get into detail because they're
quite they take a lot more time
so I'm going to reserve the stage here
now for question and answers if possible